and throughout all of this like crazy
80s Heyday and everybody's just on drugs
and everything you were never like did
you never drink or do drugs just never
never drank never did drugs um started
having glass of wine with dinner about
15 years ago me and my wife but neither
of us did um you were pretty hooked on
coffee though
right yeah it's I I read that you almost
got fired from T being too caffein I
called in I was called in for a band
meeting my first band meeting I was
pretty [__] excited CU I was younger
than the guys in the band they were they
were like a few years older than me and
there were City guys from the Bronx from
Manan I was just this dork from Long
Island I was so excited to be in the
band go to JJ French's apartment you
know I saw some hardcore porn in his
bedroom this woman with five dicks I'm
like oh man this is crazy I never saw
anything like that on Long Island and uh
and then they say oh D yeah come on
we're we're having a meeting and I
realized the whole band is sitting
across from me and I'm facing the band
I'm like oh rut R and they go
dude you got to cut back on the caffeine
the cof and I'm looking at literally a
guy who's going to AA meeting every
night the other guy's got a freaking
beer in his hand it's only like 10: in
the morning someone else has white
powder underneath his nose I mean these
are these are guys hard drugs drinking
alcoholics and I said wait a
second
my coffee drinking is bothering your
drug and alcohol use I and they told me
if they would if I didn't just cut back
they were going to have to get rid of me
what kind of coffee I mean how much how
much coffee were you drinking am I
worst three full pots so that's like 15
cups that's like a
[__] yeah three cup and then plus
they didn't have Starbucks then I was a
I love the big one go ahead that's what
she said at uh at Dunkin' Donuts so two
of those a day plus three full pots my
wife said I'd be sitting with my third
or fourth cup of coffee on the couch and
just like like a like a junkie with a
needle hanging out of his arm I'd be
sitting there never spill a drop but
just like nodded out on the with yeah I
was I was it was a problem I've cut back
it's still it's still my go-to but you
know I mean now now I've said in media
and people go you this guy takes credit
for everything he's like Jean Simmons I
say that I that twist created speed
medal and the reason why I know this to
be true is because I told you we were
vastly popular in the Northeast well all
these bands from bonjovi and Cinderella
and poison to Overkill cornivore Anthrax
they all I mean Public Enemy Chuck D
said if there was no Twisted Sister we
there'd be no Public Enemy he said I
would go see twisted and that that [__]
you attitude that that up yours attitude
they had inspired me to put PE together
so but all these bands would come see us
and and I me in Overkill documentary he
said we put Overkill together and Twi
and sister played fast so we played fast
I didn't realize how fast we were
playing cuz I was so [__] wired that
I just kept telling the B faster F I
really was and just I played everything
on until years later I've heard tapes I
go oh [__] yeah I was out of my mind on
caffeine caffeine and it's legal kids
yeah so what what when the when you get
in front of Congress like it it you
caffeined out of course I mean you were
like the face of heavy metal in front of
Congress I remember and I remember like
you know you were shockingly articulate
and intelligent but is it safe to say
that you were an
unlikely you know like why why wouldn't
they have Slayer or Blacky Lawless you
know and like like I never I understand
what you're saying if you had if they
had done their homework and gotten past
the picture and the popularity so we're
one of the biggest bands in the world
we're on the filthy 15 uh you know I
mean God bless Frank Zappa and John
Denver for standing tall when few would
but they weren't on the list so we were
literal targets so they figured oh this
guy looks like a complete
[__] you know or an incomplete [__]
which is even worse uh you know let's
get him but if they had just spent a
moment there was no social media they oh
[__] he's married he doesn't do drugs he
doesn't drink wait a second this is not
or if they look at the lyrics I use four
syllable lyrics and we're not going to
take it I mean nobody uses for you know
trit and jaded boring and confiscated I
mean that's not rock lyrics you know
that's the Declaration of independed for
God's
sakes and so they did not vet me and
they got what they they they got what
they deserved if they had gotten a Vince
Neil if they had gotten now you know
that's who they wanted they want someone
to get on I and
go thank you very much thank you very
much Mr SN yes we've heard enough do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real butt of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce for your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and sto's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude